ahora que comprendemos mejor cómo
encontrar las cifras significativas
pensemos en alguna situación en donde
sea relevante tratar con estas cifras
digamos que tenemos un tapete aquí lo
voy a dibujar más o menos así un tapete
o una alfombra y quizá usando un metro
puedo medir hasta el centímetro más
cercano y este lado de la alfombra yo
encuentro que mide 1.69 metros hasta el
centímetro más cercano así que estas
nueve centésimas de metro es lo mismo
que nueve centímetros y la base va a
medir 2.09 metros y ustedes a lo mejor
me piden calcular el área de mi alfombra
y el cálculo es bastante directo el área
es la base por la altura
un 1.69 metros
2.0 9 metros saquemos la calculadora
para hacer más rápida esta operación que
es 1.69 x 2.09 esto es igual a 3.53 21
esto es igual a 3.53 21 metros cuadrados
y pues me da mucho gusto decirles que el
área del tapete es de 3.50 y 321 metros
cuadrados el problema aquí es cuando les
doy esta cantidad todos estos números a
la derecha del punto decimal implican
que tengo una forma demasiado precisa de
medir el área cuando en realidad solo
pueda medir hasta el centímetro más
cercano para evitar aparentar que mis
medidas son más precisas de lo que
realmente son me debo asegurar de no
demostrar en el resultado más cifras
significativas de las cantidades que use
para obtener este resultado en este caso
aquí tengo tres cifras significativas
aquí también por lo tanto mi resultado
sólo puede tener tres cifras
significativas en general cuando
multiplicamos o dividimos las cifras
significativas del resultado producto o
cociente no pueden ser más que el número
de cifras significativas de las
cantidades que usamos para hacer el
cálculo en este caso mis factores tienen
tres cifras significativas por lo que mi
resultado sólo puede tener tres cifras
significativas también si un factor
tuviera tres cifras significativas y el
otro factor tuviera dos cifras nada más
el resultado sólo podría tener dos
cifras significativas así que para
mantenernos apegados a la realidad
tendremos que redondear este resultado a
tres cifras significativas más o menos
aquí es decir a la centésima más cercana
este 2 de aquí lo vamos a redondear
hacia abajo ya que es menor a 5 por lo
que esta cifra va a ser 3 puntos 53
metros cuadrados y ahora quedamos bien
con las cifras significativas
veamos otra situación pero ahora usando
la división imaginemos que voy a colocar
azulejos en una alberca mi dibujo va a
ser muy parecido al anterior
ahí está solo que aquí las dimensiones
son diferentes aquí en la altura tengo
que son 10.1 metros y aquí son 12.07
metros en este lado solo pueden medir a
la décima más cercana y esta otra
longitud por alguna razón la pude medir
hasta la centésima más cercana y los
azulejos que quiero poner en el piso de
esta alberca vamos a dibujar aquí un
azulejo tienen un área
área de 1.07 metros cuadrados a alguien
más calculó esta área por mí ahora
quiero encontrar cuando sea su lejos
necesito para cubrir este suelo de la
alberca tengo que calcular el área de
este suelo y dividirlo entre el área del
azulejo área área de del piso
de la alberca
va a ser igual
en este lado por este lado es igual a
12.07 por 10.1 metros y metros vamos a
hacer la separación sacamos de nuevo de
esta calculadora y ahora multiplicamos
12.07 por 10.1 y me queda 121.900 7 el
área del piso de la alberca es igual a
121 1.907 metros cuadrados aún no
terminamos el cálculo veamos este
operando
tiene 4 cifras significativas este de
acá tiene 3
y vemos que este pues tiene más cifras
quizás nos veamos en la tentación de
decir que como tenemos tres cifras
significativas aquí y cuatro acá pues
nuestro resultado lo querramos redondear
a tener tres cifras significativas y esa
tentación estaría bien si no tuviéramos
que hacer otro cálculo más todavía
tenemos que hacer el cálculo de cuántos
azulejos caben en este piso o en esta
área esta es una regla general para no
perder la información que aún nos puede
ser útil no redondear las cifras hasta
que hayamos encontrado nuestro resultado
final sobre todo si tenemos muchas
multiplicaciones y divisiones
si yo redondear a este resultado ahorita
estaría introduciendo un error en el
cálculo así que mantenemos el número
completo ahora vamos a hacer la división
entonces para encontrar los azulejos que
caben los azulejos que caben
el piso esto es igual lo pongo acá a
esta cantidad del área del piso de la
alberca 121.900 7 metros cuadrados entre
el área de cada azulejo vamos a ponerla
en otro color 1.0 7 metros cuadrados
hacemos esta operación de nuevo sacamos
la calculadora y tenemos 121.900 7 entre
1.0 7 y nos da 113.93 1775 70 009 34 58
y sigue entonces este resultado que lo
vamos a escribir acá en otro color es
igual a 113.93 1775
01 azulejos
azulejos aquí estas unidades se van pero
estamos buscando un número el número de
azulejos que caben en el piso esta es
nuestra respuesta final y ahora si nos
interesa tener las cifras significativas
que damos que aquí tenemos cuatro cifras
significativas acá tenemos 33 y aquí que
también lo usamos para el cálculo
tenemos 3 después de todas las
multiplicaciones y divisiones
tenemos que encontrar aquella cantidad
que usamos en nuestros cálculos que
tengan la cantidad más pequeña de cifras
significativas y esa es la cantidad de
cifras significativas que podremos tener
en nuestro resultado en este caso
nuestro resultado sólo podrá tener tres
cifras significativas así que
necesitamos redondear esto hasta el
azulejo más cercano o la unidad más
cercana entonces vemos este dígito este
de acá es un 9 vamos a hacer el redondeo
hacia arriba por lo que mi cantidad de
azulejos va a ser d
114-114 azulejos
a su lejos
ox obviamente que no sean exactamente
114 pero con base en la precisión de
nuestras medidas podemos decir que son
114 lo que hemos hecho aquí es
multiplicar y dividir cantidades con
cifras significativas y la regla general
es que el resultado sólo tendrá el
número de cifras significativas que
tenga aquella cantidad usada para hacer
los cálculos con el menor número de
estas cifras las sumas y restas son un
poco diferentes y las veremos en el
siguiente vídeo